- Do you see the beauty of it?
My swift and terrible sword,
and the Earth will crack
with the weight of your failure.
When the dust settles,
the only thing living
in this world, will be metal.
In 2015, the world
reeled from attacks from
enhanced individuals.
It was not prepared for
the tragedy in Sokovia,
under the leadership of Ultron,
a robot army descended
on the peaceful town
of Novigrad, Sokovia, a province known
for its wheat production
and fine woolen goods.
In a battle that pitted
sibling against sibling,
the otherwise sleepy town
of Novigrad was levitated
in to the sky.
Hundreds of thousands
of Sokovians perished,
and the world was forever changed.
But in the wake of the tragedy,
countries around the world
rallied around a common cause,
in response to the Sokovian tragedy
and the supervillian Ultron,
the world knew what it needed,
to regulate enhanced individuals.
That is legally problematic.
(guitar playing)
Hey LegalEagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer.
Welcome back to Laws
Broken, where an attorney
destroys your favorite childhood movies,
by showing you how illegal everything is,
because everything is illegal.
Today we're talking
about the Sokovia Accords
from "Captain America's Civil War"
and the rest of the "Avengers" movies.
We're going to pretend
that it is an actual
binding, legal document and analyze it
in far, far, too much detail.
For better or worse, in the
wake of the Ultron disaster,
countries worldwide,
through the United Nations,
signed the Sokovia Accords.
The Sokovia Accords are
a phone book sized set
of regulations aimed squarely
at the Avengers personally,
and the organization S.H.E.I.L.D.
It seeks to limit the
so-called enhanced individuals,
including registration components,
monitoring components, and
imprisonment components.
I'm using the version
of the Sokovia Accords
found at the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Fandom Wiki,
which you can find at the link below.
Importantly, some of the
provisions only apply
to signatories of the Sokovia Accords,
while other provisions apply
to all enhanced individuals,
whether they sign or not.
This is quite the constitutional problem.
So because this is
obviously the most important
legal analysis that I could
possibly be doing right now,
I put together 10 reasons
why the Sokovia Accords
raise constitutional questions.
But first, I want to talk
about the legal landscape
in general, specifically
whether the Sokovia Accords
would even be U.S. law and number two,
what would the legal
framework be for dealing
with enhanced individuals in the absence
of the Sokovia Accords?
So first, let's talk about
the Accords in general.
An accord is not a U.S. law,
I assume what the Marvel
writers meant here is that
the Sokovia Accords are
an international treaty
that the U.S. has signed.
But just because 177
countries signed an agreement,
doesn't actually make it
law in the United States.
In the case of a treaty,
the Senate has to approve
the treaty by a 2/3 vote
under Article II, Section 2
of the Constitution.
And there are tons of examples of treaties
that the U.S. has signed
but not actually ratified,
that includes the International
Criminal Court Treaty,
the Comprehensive Nuclear Test Ban Treaty,
the Kyoto Protocol, and
the Treaty of Versailles,
basically the U.S. is
still in World War I.
But for the sake of
argument, let's assume that
the U.S. Senate has, in fact,
ratified the Sokovia Accords,
it's more fun that way, in any event,
even when treaties are ratified,
they cannot violate the U.S. Constitution,
and, in fact, this was
an issue when the U.S.
adopted NATO, because it was thought
that the Mutual Defense
Treaty would violate
Congress' right to declare war.
But before we get to analyzing
the actual Sokovia Accords
themselves, we have to
examine the status quo ex ante
of U.S. criminal law and tort law.
Captain America chafes at the restrictions
of the Sokovia Accords, but
it's not like in the absence
of the Accords, he'd be
allowed to operate domestically
in the United States.
Vigilantes are illegal, as
we discussed in the video
on the "Dark Knight" and all
the laws that Batman broke.
You can't just go around
getting in to fights,
even for a good cause.
The justification of
self-defense generally doesn't
apply when you intentionally
put yourself in harm's way.
And all of these enhanced
individuals are using
deadly force, which almost
always carries with it
a duty to retreat if
you are able to do so.
Of course, U.S. law
doesn't necessarily apply
to the Avenger's actions in Sokovia
and other foreign countries.
But the fact of the matter
is, they are often operating
domestically where U.S. law does apply.
Don't even get me started
about issues of federalism
because even if enhanced
individuals were allowed,
under the Sokovia Accords
on the federal level,
there's still all the state laws
that prohibit their actions.
And there's no way
federal law would preempt
garden variety state laws
about criminal conduct.
Now you might argue that
it seems like the Avengers
in S.H.E.I.L.D. are operating
as an arm of the government,
essentially like mercenaries,
which might have given them
legal cover under the battle of New York,
but if that's so, that
they're operating as an arm
of the U.S. government, that
carries with it all kinds
of constitutional protections
and that doesn't get them
out of trouble.
By the way, Tony Stark created Ultron,
and effectively Ultron is
his product entered in to
the stream of commerce,
so Tony Stark is probably
personally liable on a product's liability
or negligence theory for all
the damage that Ultron did.
And since this is a Marvel movie,
I put an after-credits
bonus scene about that topic
at the end of this video.
But the fact that the
writers even considered
any of these legal issues is why
the adoption of Sokovia Accords
is the best scene in the MCU.
- Actually the best scene in
the MCU is the after party
from "Age of Ultron"
because of how effectively
it uses a light, fun
moment between the Avengers
to reveal important
information about the main
characters while still
being a funny scene.
- Actually the best scene in the MCU
is the I'm Always Angry" scene
from the first "Avengers"
because it's just so iconic.
- Well actually, I'd say that
the best scene in the MCU
is the military propaganda
montage in the original
"Captain America" movie
because no other scene is so
subversive, over-the-top,
and hilarious all ...
- Yeah, this is my court,
objections overruled.
But let's ignore those
issues and let's talk about
the 10 biggest problems
with the U.S. version
of the Sokovia Accords.
So in order of ascending
constitutional infirmity,
let's start with the
compelled speech portion
of the Sokovia Accords.
The Sokovia Accords state, and I quote,
"Any enhanced individual who agree to sign
must register with the
United Nations and provide
biometric data such as
fingerprints and DNA samples..."
"Those with secret
identities must reveal their
legal names and true identities
to the United Nations..."
This is a classic provision
of compelled speech,
some of which applies to signatories
and some of which does
not apply to signatories.
But forcing individuals to give up their
secret identities is the
government compelling you
to make a certain kind of speech.
- I am Iron Man.
- And if the first amendment has a problem
with the government
restricting certain speech,
you can imagine that it
is doubly problematic
if it forces individuals to
make a certain kind of speech.
For example, in the Supreme Court case
of West Virginia School
Board vs. Barnette,
the Supreme Court said that
a school could not force
students to stand and salute the flag.
That was compelled speech.
And in the same way that
you can't force individuals
to stand up and salute the flag,
you can't force people to give
up their secret identities
and provide biometric
data and fingerprints
to the U.S. government.
Number two, forced registration sounds
a lot like internment.
The Sokovia Accords requires
all enhanced individuals
to at least register with the government,
whether they are using
their powers or not,
which sounds a lot like the internment
of the Japanese in World War
II under executive order 9066
by President Roosevelt.
That executive order was tested
at the Supreme Court level
in a court case Korematsu,
and the Supreme Court did not
overrule the executive order,
which interned the Japanese.
Korematsu is still good law.
That being said, I doubt
the Supreme Court would
rule the same way today,
despite the fact that the ruling
has never been overturned.
But in any event, it seems
like this is a clear violation
of the fourth and fifth
amendment protections
and a requirement for due process.
Number three, monitoring
of enhanced individuals.
This seems like a clear
fourth amendment problem.
The Sokovia Accords state, and I quote,
"Those with innate powers must also wear
tracking bracelets at all times..."
The problem is warrantless
monitoring without
probable cause; just because someone is an
enhanced individual would be a clear
fourth amendment violation,
a violation of the right to privacy,
being enhanced doesn't
necessarily mean that you have
probable cause to monitor them.
And it would be crazy to have
a blanket monitoring system
that monitored everyone
in the United States
without probable cause.
So it's very good the U.S.
government has never had
a program like that,
to monitor people without probable cause.
(loon singing)
The Sokovia Accords also state that,
"Those with innate powers must submit
to a power analysis, which
will categorize their
threat level and determine
potential health risks..."
This feels like a huge violation
of the right to privacy.
The government can't just go around doing
medical examinations of
individuals just because
it feels like it or because
it's in the public interest.
People have individual rights
specifically to protect
them from this kind of invasive testing.
And additionally, it would
probably be a violation
of Tony Stark's intellectual property.
Even if he hasn't patented
the Iron Man suit,
it would probably be a trade secret,
and the compelled power
analysis would probably violate
his IP rights to the suit that he created.
- It's working, we're safe.
America is secure.
You want my property?
You can't have it.
- Number four, the second
amendment's individual
right to bear arms.
While this is still a
huge point of controversy,
in recent Supreme Court precedent,
in the District of Columbia vs. Heller,
the Supreme Court confirmed
that the second amendment
does provide an individual
right to bear arms.
So, what is the threshold
for Iron Man, Falcon,
and War Machine to be able
to use their inventions
that they created effectively,
the Iron Man suits or the Falcon machinery
are just arms that they have created
and certainly, in some circumstances,
you are allowed to an individual
right to bear those arms.
Now obviously, individuals are not allowed
to have military hardware,
but the Sokovia Accords
don't make it clear where the
individual right to bear arms
starts and where the exclusion
of military technology
kicks in and how that would
apply to the individuals
who are not innately
enhanced, but have created
an enhanced suit for themselves.
- I have successfully
privatized world peace.
(Crowd clapping)
So given the make up of
the current Supreme Court
and the deference shown to the
individual right to bear arms
under the second
amendment, you can bet that
the Sokovia Accords probably
run afoul of that right
under the Constitution as well.
Number five, a violation of
the freedom to associate.
The Sokovia Accords apply
to all of the Avengers,
even those who are not enhanced,
effectively preventing
them from being a member
of this community or group.
Now the first amendment is most famous for
the individual right to freedom of speech,
but the lesser known right
of the first amendment
is the right to voluntarily associate.
And the Sokovia Accords
prevent individuals
from associating with
the private organization
called the Avengers and
called S.H.E.I.L.D.
Just because you are
an enhanced individual
doesn't mean you lack
first amendment rights
to be a part of the group that
you want to participate in.
Number six, violation of
the freedom to travel.
The Sokovia Accords state, and I quote,
"Any enhanced individuals
who sign are prohibited
from taking action in any
country other than their own,
unless they are first
given clearance by either
that country's government
or by a United Nation's subcmomittee..."
- Think of it this way, your
school has rules, right?
Like you can't draw on the walls.
Well your daddy went to
Germany and drew on the walls
with Captain America,
and that was a violation
of Article 16, paragraph
three of the Sokovia Accords.
- Now the defined term taking action
can be read very broadly.
Would that prohibit all of the Avengers
from setting foot in
any particular country
without getting the United
Nations subcommittee
to allow them to travel?
And would it prevent them
from traveling domestically
in the United States?
If it does, that's clearly a violation
of the privileges and immunities clause
of the U.S. Constitution.
And not to mention, the
violation of various
International laws that
allow freedom of travel,
particularly between the U.S. and E.U.
I think that this is a
poorly drafted statement,
and it shows how important it is to define
the terms that you're dealing with,
because otherwise, people
will read them broadly,
when they're written
broadly, and it can have
unintended consequences.
Which takes me to problem number seven,
which is vagueness.
There is a constitutional
rule that requires
criminal laws to state
explicitly and definitively,
what conduct is punishable.
Criminal laws that
violate this requirement
are said to be void on vagueness grounds.
The vagueness doctrine is based
on the due process clauses
of the fifth and 14th
amendments to the Constitution.
And I think that there's
a big problem here
in terms of what the enhanced individuals
are being accused of; vague
terms like taking action,
vague terms as in what constitutes
an enhanced individual itself,
all of these are vagueness
issues that are probably
so vague as to run afoul
of the due process clauses
in the Constitution.
That's why you need lawyers
to draft these things,
not comic book artists, but I digress.
It takes me to issue number eight,
which is imprisonment.
The Sokovia Accords effectively
treat enhanced individuals
who fail to comply with
the Sokovia Accords
as enemy combatants.
Now it's one thing to
send enemy combatants
that are imprisoned in
a foreign theater of war
and send them to Guantanamo,
but it's another thing
entirely to send U.S. citizens,
who were found in the United States,
to the equivalent of Guantanamo
on some Helicarrier someway.
This is a clear due process violation.
You can't just put people
inside of a Helicarrier
with no lawyer, no
arraignment, and no bail.
That's clearly a sixth amendment violation
to the right to council.
- You're not gonna put me in a prison.
You're not gonna put
any of us in a prison.
- And the other side of the
coin in problem number nine,
which is forced conscription in to combat.
The Sokovia Accords
appear to force certain
enhanced individuals in to fighting
for the U.S. government
in certain times of war,
effectively the draft,
but it's another thing
entirely to seek out
certain individuals specifically,
and then force them in to combat
on behalf of the government.
This seems like a clear violation
of the 13th amendment's prohibition
against involuntary servitude.
You might recall that we
fought a real civil war
to prevent involuntary
servitude and slavery,
and forcing enhanced individuals to fight
for the government seems to run
afoul of those prohibitions.
Which takes me to problem number 10,
and the biggest constitutional violation,
the violation against habeus corpus.
Habeus corpus is Latin
for produce the body.
And the Sokovia Accords
state, and I quote,
"Any individuals who use
their powers to break the law,
including those who take
part in extra legal vigilante
activities or are otherwise
deemed to be a threat
to the safety of the general
public may be detained
indefinitely without trial."
"If an enhanced individual
violates the Accords
or obstructs the actions of
those enforcing the Accords,
they may likewise be arrested and detained
indefinitely without trial..."
You might see where this is going,
but simply, detaining people
indefinitely without trial
is the classic constitutional problem.
And in fact, just simply
deeming someone a threat,
before they have committed
any kind of events
is like a precrime prohibition,
which again, runs afoul
of the Constitution.
The writ of habeus corpus
requires a person in custody
to be brought before a
court, provided a lawyer
if they can't afford
one, and to be protected
by the U.S. Constitution.
We fought the war of Independence
to have the protections
of the Constitution to prevent things like
indefinite imprisonment
for no reason whatsoever.
This violates the fourth
amendment which protects
people from arbitrary arrests.
It violates the fifth
amendment's protection against
being deprived of life,
liberty, and property
without due process.
And it violates the sixth
amendment's right to council
and a trial.
There's actually very few
parts of the Constitution
that this part of the Sokovia
Accords don't actually
violate, and that's why the lawyers
are the real superheroes
in the Marvel Universe.
(patriotic music)
So in thinking about this
Ultron Vision problem
a little bit more, Tony created Vision,
Vision is Tony's property, his chattel,
so legally speaking,
Vision is like Tony's dog.